all that [ __ ] they taught you in the
academy about procedure and probable
cause [ __ ] that now this is baltimore
we hadn't been here in 15 years it felt
like a homecoming in some respects
being back in baltimore is great we're
very specific to this city and and the
people the story caught our attention
because having done the wire we were
critiquing the drug war
and now there's a level of darkness here
that has to be addressed please let me
see your hands
task force we come to [ __ ] hunt as
long as we put those numbers up we can't
lose
every time i put on that uniform
i walk the street and people have
stories about wayne jenkins
you shoot on a block where there's
people who have been affected by what
these men did
wayne jenkins stories legendary in the
city of baltimore
just being on set watching some of the
scenes play out it was almost spooky
because it's like yo this is what
happens this is how it is
there is a familial spirit among the
folks that make the show that come from
the wire there's a spirit to baltimore
it's got so much scrap and vigor it's
unlike anything i've ever seen in 20
years of doing this there is so much
warmth in the way that people greet you
i mean i don't think i've been invited
to so many people's houses for dinner
[Music]
when you're in the real space where it
actually took place
as an artist you realize it's kind of
like the spirit that reaches out and
touches you you know it's like that
thing that's happening in between it
makes the show that much more authentic
the space in the environment is so real
you can feel that on set
a lot of our extras and supporting
artists were there telling us what it
felt like
it happened in baltimore and we're here
walking in their shoes now meeting
people that they affected to hear people
talk about how they remember being
pulled over by one of these guys that's
still reverberating this many years
later
everyone who lives here knows what time
it is police treating all of us like
criminals people like me my family the
main character of the wire is baltimore
it's no different here this is an
examination of baltimore i am so in love
with this city because of the resiliency
of what this city has had to overcome
david and george care deeply about the
communities which they represent they
care deeply about populating these
stories with real folks so many people
locally were able to just play a part on
camera off camera behind the scenes i
hope the city of baltimore feels
vindicated in a way i hope people feel
seen
look around
you build this machine
watch it work they want this story to be
told they want people to know what
happened here in the city of baltimore
no we are the gun trace task force
[Music]
go out there and give them help
[Music]
you